you know it only started singing what
and now we're back now welcome back to
the evident caitlyn podcast this is my
podcasting voice move on so in today's
episode we're gonna be talking about our
old jobs because it's a question that we
get asked a lot and I think that just be
good to i funk I thought it'd just be
fun to kind of have a podcast about that
that we can refer people back to going
forward and stuff to talk about yeah
yeah and then um we also speaking of
questions that we get a lot we're also
going to be doing our first Q&A segment
with questions from our patreon
supporters um so do you wanna start with
talking about your job yeah so I
graduated college with a degree in
engineering and like the details aren't
that interesting I think that the more
interesting thing that we can talk about
is kind of what we got from each job
are we like glad that we did that work
there and like kind of looking back
would we do things differently you know
from our perspective right now yeah and
like I don't just generally it's kind of
a crazy career path because okay so I
graduated engineering and you graduated
I was a marketing major marketing major
but you always knew that you're gonna be
doing art that was your goal from like I
knew I wanted to do alright but I also
wanted to never have a job that paid
money yeah money so I I figured I can
figure out the art stuff on my own cuz I
had always just figured out on my own
and the thing I would study would be the
stuff that might be harder to figure out
of my own which is what I went into
graphic design interestingly you almost
went to Savannah we like we wouldn't be
here we wouldn't have this life this
relationship all this crazy stuff got
into I'm super
you didn't go there I got in I got in
but I was like at the last minute I was
like if I go to an art school and I
changed my mind about wanting to major
in art yeah I there's only so much you
can pivot yeah if you're at an art
school so instead I found a liberal art
school that had a good art program but
also had a bunch of other good stuff
yeah and luckily you're there too yeah
that's so crazy
now looking back are you glad that you
got a degree in business as opposed to
art I mean nothing nothing's obviously
wrong about getting art degree some
people just know and and you know that
helps build up a portfolio and stuff
like I think that's one of the main
advantages going to like an art college
you get more experience with art and you
build a portfolio right honestly I think
both would have been kind of equally me
that sounds like I'm anti education I
think education is good but yeah I feel
like no matter what you you go into I
think unless you are studying something
that is more like a doctor like a doctor
or like an engineer yeah you know
there's a lot of like very hard skills
that have to be learned whereas I think
with things like marketing for example
it's softer skills are like people
skills and presentation skills and
working with the team skills yeah like
nobody goes crap about with the four
piece of marketing are you know nobody
asked me that when I started making what
are the four piece of marketing product
price promotion you're gonna get a 75%
on this test three to 75 percent Kaylee
looks like your worst grade you've ever
gotten ever and I think for me I think
one of the best things about the college
that I went to is every single semester
for eight you know the eight semesters
that I went there there was always a
design class like hands-on skills that I
think really prepped me prepared me for
like the real world better than almost
anything else like those those eight
design classes I think were the most
valuable thing plus senior year they
paired us with an actual company and we
solved a legit problem for them
we're like there was you know
requirement put into place and real
world like its consequences if ya did
things wrong and stuff I feel like they
should have that every single semester
for every major yeah I don't know even
if like your role when you're like a
freshman even if your role is less
crucial to that real-life project you
still kind of get experience get to work
with it and then as you go like by the
time your senior you are playing a more
active role in it it would still give
you experience yeah one of the cool
things I did actually was your first job
because that was really cool
one of the cool things was that we had
some like flexibility especially like
upperclassmen yeah and so I could do I
figured was called like a self-guided
class oh yeah I could basically just
choose an instructor and be like hey I
want to do this for my class can I do
this and they would grade me it was
basically like that's how I started my
LLC yeah this is because you took
business and that's kind of what helped
my freelancing then rememberest was
starting my own business for like free
like doing freelance art that's so cool
and so it was like going through legal
stuff and starting it yeah but that was
like my class and you did it I did it
yeah so you started your LLC you like in
college a long time ago yeah I think
that another interesting thing about
both of our career paths is we both
worked for big companies and smaller
companies I think that perspective is
really interesting plus we've both done
freelancing we both kind of done the
whole gambit of the different types of
work environments that you can have yeah
yeah that's very true I think one really
interesting thing that I kind of got
from working for other companies is I
think that if you if you never work and
those bigger types of companies where
there is low you know budgets and team
meetings and you know proper protocol
you kind of need to follow when pitching
ideas are doing presentations or what
have you I don't think I'd be like I
don't think either of us really you
might be organized but I wouldn't be as
organized as I am now as methodical like
you know when I reach out to companies I
know
kind of what they want because I've been
in their shoes a little bit yeah you
know it's like you know and I've been
around people who are making those types
of decisions so I think that you know if
I were to do it over again I wouldn't
just go straight into like if I was
giving my younger self advice I wouldn't
just go straight into YouTube I don't
think what about you yeah but I yeah
it's hard to say whether or not I would
do it differently if I like went back in
time with all my current knowledge but I
do think that there's a lot of valuable
stuff I think one of the big things that
I picked up from my work experience this
is kind of confidence in myself my
abilities in terms of talking with you
know suppliers and customers and like
supply chain managers and stuff like
that like just kind of that back end of
the business thing that's true because
sometimes we'll talk to people who are
like reaching out for advice or things
like that they're like how do you how do
you talk to companies like that's so
scary how do you reach out the sponsors
and for us it was never a scary thing
because it's like he was writing email
the same way you'd write an email if you
know when we were working our you know
normal jobs you know you needed to ask
somebody for something yeah you know
it's kind of just it's kind of just the
same thing
but I think like that is something that
comes kind of with practice maybe yeah
yeah so quick question for you I have a
question so you've done freelancing but
have I told people what I did
Oh probably not I was a marketing major
yeah actually all my jobs were in
graphic design yeah yeah graphic design
but I think it's really interesting that
you worked for two small startup
companies yeah you did freelancing just
for yourself as your own company yeah in
two separate time frames and you worked
for a really big company what was
advantages and disadvantages of each
circumstance and compare freelance all
by yourself first freelance and we're
kind of freelancers in that way I don't
know yeah
um I feel like with the small companies
because I worked to one was awesome it
was super fun kind of to the point I was
like it was probably too fun because the
company eventually went under so like we
were maybe playing too much and not
working enough but it was it was really
fun it was a really positive experience
um the second small company was kind of
miserable honestly those are because of
the people there is because also kind of
like the second one it kind of showed me
like if if you're gonna hire people on
you need to be ready for that cuz I was
hired on and they were not ready yeah to
have an employee and that's something
I've actually thought about for our
business too because you know I was
hired on because they were really behind
on all their projects and I the work
work worked worked for a month and I got
caught up on everything that they
expected to take a year and then I was
like okay great no it that's because
here it is awesome well it's also
because they like severely this
estimated how long that would take but I
think that was kind of like a sign of
like small companies are great but you
gotta make sure it's sustainable make
sure it's sustainable yeah and then you
know the working for a big company was
like very cool especially in the
beginning it was very like with
corporate you know and the people were
super super cool I do think the main
downside of that for me was when I
started to look forward and I was like
okay what's my what would be my future
here and the only way to progress really
you know and this this isn't unique to
this company is just something I happen
to be looking at when I was at this
company as a graphic designer you can
only progress so far like you can only
go up like one more level and then after
that period or something yeah and then
after that you're a manager yeah and I
was like - I really want to manage
people like I like graphic design stuff
but it's also I've been doing it for a
few years and the stuff I'm
doing is getting kind of old but I don't
necessarily want to be a manager's like
what do I do
yeah and like looking forward through
your whole career like through the
reason why you wanted to do what you're
doing is so you could create things and
be creative yeah not so you could manage
people well that's not to say there's
not creativity in a managerial job it's
just a different type of creativity and
it's not one that I want it mm-hmm and
so yeah that's one of the things that
really got me thinking about it but then
like in terms of freelance going to that
yeah yeah
in terms of freelance it was really
interesting because I did freelance
graphic design like Evan said like it
you know in between jobs and two
different quick two years yeah and you
know I it was probably at the point
where I was doing it you know more than
part-time hours but it definitely wasn't
at fully full-time hours yeah I mean
it's it's hard especially kind of like
as a artist planning our wedding and
stuff so I was working on we're planning
the wedding we just bought a house you
know were getting super aggressive about
pulling in new clients no yeah I wasn't
getting super aggressive and I kind of
didn't have too much drive to get like
that aggressive ya know um it was like
we were not stressed about money I was
having fun planning the wedding and
helping fix up the house and all that
stuff and it
I liked the flexibility of being a
freelance graphic designer but it also
did get old in its own ways yeah you
know like I didn't have you know again
looking forward it was like okay this is
cool but you know what is what is my
path moving forward how do I keep this
exciting and I you know I liked it but I
wasn't like crazy passionate about yeah
that's interesting yeah I think for me
different than this yeah it's very
different than this I think for me it's
um comparing the big company versus the
two small companies it's very
interesting because your two small
companies were very different and my two
small companies were very different too
I think that the the first smaller
company that I started at
they kind of like your second small
company they weren't utilizing me to my
full advantage you know like there's a
long lead for like the items that we
were sending out to get made there's a
lot of waiting time and I think that the
those days just went by so slowly it was
like was painfully slow honestly yeah
and and then my second small company it
was the opposite of that I was working
all the time I was stressed all the time
I got to work and the day was done it
was like 8:00 and like I'd come home I'd
eat real quick and then basically go to
bed and repeat what do you think is
worse which situation the ones where the
day drags on but it's pretty easy or the
one where it's a lot of working out so
much time it kind of depends on what
else is going on in your life almost you
know I think that I think that it I
think that if you Val like if you were
doing meaningful work at your job but
you maybe didn't have enough to do or
like you weren't 100% fully occupied but
you still felt your time was being well
used and you had a lot of fun things
going on in your life outside of work
you could look forward to I think I
might prefer that long term as opposed
to being stressed and overworked all the
time even though those years went by
really fast those days went really by
fast they kind of disappeared yeah you
know I think that when when I was at the
other job and I had a little bit more
time I still was doing good stuff
accomplished good things I felt good
about the designs I was doing but the
days did go by a little bit slower I
felt like that time in my life was more
meaningful because I had time to live my
own life yeah I mean yeah I don't know I
think I would agree with that even
though like I think generally the best
is like to have enough work to keep you
busy for the amount of hours that you're
supposed to be working you know when you
have like a normal job and there's
certain set hours you're supposed to be
working but yeah the other like your
other job where you were just working so
much all the time that was pretty
extreme that was pretty extreme now
looking back on it I mean I do this
weird thing or
I think about life as a video game and I
think about like leveling up and gaining
skills and all this stuff I think that
when I was at the first small company
and I wasn't being utilized I felt like
I was leveling up really slowly it was
like I wasn't developing as many skills
as fast like I did take a lot of things
upon myself like I learned how to do 3d
animations I learned how to do polygonal
3d modeling as opposed to just you know
parametric I don't know parametric like
geometry based math based modeling it's
funny because like when I was at my job
where they were underutilizing me I
taught myself like HTML and CSS and like
code basic websites yeah that's awesome
but I think that at the company where I
was working all the time I developed a
lot more as a professional I wore a lot
of hats I was exposed to like a whole
bunch of situations and I felt like I
did level up as an engineer as a kind of
worker I don't know maybe it'd be like
if let's say you're like single living
in a city and like your friends were
work friends yeah I think maybe the
latter situation might be better yeah
you know like yeah you're spending a lot
of time at work but all your friends are
also spending a lot of time we work and
like you don't feel like there's other
that sounds kind of sad but like you
don't feel like there's other stuff that
you're missing out on because you're at
work yeah you know whereas I think the
situation where the day goes kind of
slow would probably be better if like
you had a family or you know things like
that where yeah the day might go by slow
but then you still overall had more time
outside of work yeah yeah yeah I don't
know I think we talked about it a little
bit earlier but what do you think
working at those other jobs helps bring
to YouTube like our YouTube career and
stuff because I could think of a few
more things besides just like being able
to send emails yeah I think um I mean
this isn't this is not an exact answer
to that question but I do think working
tip like working a typical job made me
appreciate the like positives of our job
now oh you know what I mean and like
understand the cost of our job now
because the positives are it's awesome
we love it we feel super fulfilled doing
it we really like the work we do every
day the cost is the time takes a lot
more a lot more time it's a lot more
work than any other jobs
we worked before and I think having that
perspective like you know if you had
never worked an office job or you know
and we didn't even get into like our pre
does they're all like our post college
jobs you don't get into like our retail
jobs and things like that
my lifeguarding years and previous
things too but yeah I feel like those
other experiences help you like like
when things are hard at this job there's
been lots of times I'm like you know
this is stressful but I'd still rather
be doing this because I have that
comparison yeah I think that helps I
think that maybe we had have just jumped
into this we might not have valued it as
much yeah I think it might be easier to
get burnt out because like it's it's
easy to say the grass is greener on the
other side when you've never been on
that grass yeah you know I think another
thing that are our jobs helped with I
mean you know from a very utilitarian
point of view I mean one thing that they
did is working our two jobs let us save
up enough money that we felt comfortable
jumping into this that's true I mean
that's that's a huge part of it yeah and
like specifically for our type of
channel that we're doing you know we
require a workshop and those jobs let us
buy a house yeah you know this is a very
utilitarian but it is true it'd be a be
a lot harder to do what we do if we're
still in the apartment yeah and also I
mean for the very first year of evident
Cailin we made very little money yeah
very low very little money on the
channel but we didn't lose money in our
bank accounts because we were still
working yeah because we're still working
yeah I think that another thing that I
think really helps us now is I mean this
is specifically for us you know everyone
runs their YouTube channel differently
and you know some people don't need
schedules and some people don't need
like goals and budgets and deliverables
but I think that
like this this sounds so nerdy but like
sometimes like after we have like a
meeting between the two of us like okay
what are the action items what are you
gonna do what am I gonna do what's the
next like plan of action well we know we
make the lists we make the like
deliverables and everything and when we
are on the phone with with companies we
know like say like okay so what are you
gonna do and what are we gonna do and
like what's the next steps you know like
what's that like I set the date let's
set the meetings let's said all of that
I think another thing is I mean I think
I've probably talked about err table
before that's where we keep track of all
of our projects but for the next usually
six months or so or you know between two
and six months we have all of our
projects planned we have what dates
they're gonna be on we have you know who
we're gonna be working with we have all
of that scheduled and laid out and
organized and I think that has led us do
a lot of things it's let us make more
money it's let us be more strap Oh be
less just about all these unknowns I
think that we have brought a lot of
those businesses kills over on to our
you know our our content creation
business because it is a business also I
feel like legit when we're talking to
people and I'm like okay you know we're
talking a sponsorship I'm like okay so
what's the call to action we should hit
but I'm like yeah I know it's like dumb
stuff but yeah it sometimes we do feel
like we're like I don't know I do feel
like we've been able to bring a lot of
those skills yeah yeah yeah I'm not sure
if we've talked about this too much I
mean we've talked to so many people in
like done a few talks about YouTube and
YouTube
you know the shifting of our careers
over to YouTube have we talked about how
we in particular just like the two of us
how we managed our two careers as we
switched from our engineering and
graphic design jobs over to YouTube
I like how we transitioned yeah podcast
without the interesting I think maybe
know what I just don't know if you
haven't heard this good if you have I'm
sorry
eighteen episodes and we can't remember
what we've talked about that's pretty
bad yeah how we transitioned from our
full-time jobs to doing YouTube yeah so
for me in particular I quit my job as an
engineer and then I offered my services
as a freelancer like consultant doing
basically the same thing yeah it was
like a that happened at one time it
wasn't like you quit and then you later
offered yeah I would like to switch from
being a full-time employee to a
consultant I am oh yeah but yeah yeah
but yeah I'm doing this and I hope you
guys get on board basically yeah and it
worked out you know and and I I brought
on a few more clients but my main client
for most of my consulting days was my
previous company yeah yeah and then
since you were consulting as week kept
ramping up YouTube you are able to
gradually decrease your hours consulting
like at your own will basically and it
kind of worked out too because when when
you're hiring someone as a consultant
you don't want them to work any more
than they need to you know because
you're paying them hourly it's a very
evident cost of more work more cost yeah
and I think that the main thing that I
wanted to do is reduce my hours so I was
fine working at that rate but I also
kind of it was kind of a good situation
that they wanted to use me as little as
they they could yeah experience yeah if
you worked less or you were more
efficient you were benefiting them yes
yes and also benefitting you and
benefiting me so this worked out pretty
well yeah and you know and I didn't
leave them hanging I felt good that I
left on good terms and you know all the
time you could love fully like they had
I had transitioned everything over and
it felt good it felt right mine was very
different
mine was maybe a little shaky er yeah I
would say so
I like did some digging because Evan had
already switched to consulting so like
we were on my insurance and so I'd done
some digging and saw that I could go
down to 20 hours and still qualify for
insurance like I wouldn't get all the
benefits but it's still getting
trance mmm and so even though it wasn't
typical for graphic designers at my
company to do this I just asked and I
was like hey can I cut from 40 hours to
30 hours I'll take a cut in pay like you
know whatever we need to do but can I do
this and that essentially meant like me
taking Friday's off and you told them
that you were very serious about it
I told him I was very serious about I
told him you know that it was very
important to me and that I also thought
that you know I I could get everything
done I needed to get done and what's so
it's so funny I don't know this is kind
of a side tangent but the funniest thing
is you were so efficient after that
point that no one even noticed that you
were part-time yeah except that you were
gone one day out of the week yeah yeah
that was the thing that a lot of people
didn't know that I had cut from 40 to 30
like eventually people started wondering
like yeah like you know there's extra
space when you're working a nine-to-five
and your schedule like and you were just
incentivized and rewarded for getting
done faster in a way you know yeah it
was kind of a good deal both ways always
because they were getting the same
amount of work and they're paying us the
only bad deal is that people start
asking questions and that made
management like kind of uncomfortable
with the situation cuz they didn't want
to make it look like they were playing
favorites even though this is
technically nothing outside of company
policy yeah I've never been done on our
team yeah and so I was like okay well
what if I went like to part-time like we
just made it really evident there was no
like is she full-time but she gets
Friday's off what's that I was like I'll
just do 20 hours yeah
and so we did that for a while and you
didn't get benefits then and that's when
I owe ya this is you know I simplified
my story I did go back full-time for a
bit
welcome back full-time for like a month
or two Moltres time because yeah because
we hated insurance and then after two
months of me working 20 hours a week my
company was like hey we either need you
to come back full-time or we need you to
quit so we have enough budget to hire a
full-time person yeah
quit so that happened a little
preemptively but by the time I I had
fully quit like we knew the path yeah
we're on we've been doing it on the side
long enough and we saw where I was going
with the income and the money and and
all of that jazz and at that point I
still was had like more stable income
source through consulting the consulting
yeah even when I quit you were still
consulting pretty regularly yeah and I
mean we would just decided we had to
figure out insurance I think that I in
general I also did like consulting yeah
abuse an amount you never like go back
to that in the future I mean you know
was it kind of like freelancing was for
me where it's like I like the freedom of
this this is pretty enjoyable yeah but
like I don't have I didn't have the
drive to put in more hours than I ever
would at a nine-to-five I think that
maybe and I don't ever see us getting
tired of making evident Caitlin videos
especially because you know we have our
main videos we have the podcast we have
gaming and in our main channel we can do
a variety of things so if we ever get
tired of woodworking we can do a bob
ross painting tutorial or we can do
welding or we can do so many things I
think that flexibility is like a huge
huge advantage of how we've set our
channel up because I just don't see us
ever really getting tired of like
looking into the future I'm just excited
about all of it which is a really lucky
place to be at well we've set it up
around stuff we like doings yeah that
helps that really yeah but I think that
in general like if I was doing
consulting around YouTube or content
creation or something like that I think
that I'd actually enjoy that more you
know like meet you like maybe helping a
channel get up and running that we you
know I believe strongly and or what have
you you know like something like that I
think I would be more interested in yeah
that you don't have the time right now
but I think that like you know something
like that
it might be interesting yeah at some
point in the future yeah yeah
so would you so like looking at our path
would you recommend it as a path if
someone wanted to do something similar
to what we're doing we can I guess we
kind of already talked about that I
think the main thing I'd recommend after
going through everything we've gone
through is explore your options be open
to trying new things take risks and
really try to figure out what you really
want to do and I know that sounds kind
of cliche and everything but it's not
like follow your passion I'm not sure
but it's like try things out see if you
get excited about doing it see if you're
good at it because I think that another
thing I mean the sounds kind of weird
but I think everyone likes doing stuff
they're good at yeah and they get a lot
of joy from that like if you're very
skilled at something you can find joy
and a lot of things so I think I think
that that yeah figure out what you're
good at see if you really like it and
but I think the biggest thing is if
you're in a position and I think that
this is a position of like being lucky
and stuff but if you're in the position
to like take chances and try new things
I'd say just go for it yeah whether that
new thing is YouTube you know you want
to start a YouTube channel or if that
new thing is like you want to start your
own business selling products your own
business doing consulting like or go for
it but I also say if you're a cautious
person because I'm a cautious person go
for it but with a plan to do it in baby
steps like we've done yeah
you know I think there's anything wrong
with that like just cuz you didn't storm
into your boss's office and say I quit
and then start your business the next
day yeah that doesn't mean that there's
any there's anything like I don't know
wrong wrong yeah yeah like you can do it
in baby steps that doesn't have to be
like a dramatic dramatic change all at
once yeah so going through all of the
things that like working for those old
companies did for us and everything
I'm just curious what do you think like
if we had have started evident Kalin
somehow right out of college I mean
there's a lot of logistical challenges
why it wouldn't work like I worry about
money and stuff yeah well like I wonder
what we would have done I think a lot of
epicMealTime at the time kind of like
more chaotic it wouldn't have as much of
a plan and thought behind it I think I
probably yeah I think I would probably
just make videos that I thought were fun
are funny
which might which might have gone well
which might have gone really well yeah
but I don't know how good they would
have been and I don't know if there
might be stuff online that I might
regret later
oh yeah I think that that would have
been a strong possibility yeah
well I think after asking each other so
many questions I think we should give
our patrons a chance yes yes okay we
need to have a theme song here
is that a new cue a theme song yeah I
think so I just like we just sat here in
silence for a little bit I'm sure this
happened one of us will figure out
something nice and posts okay all right
so our patron Jesse Allen asks at what
point do you think you would bring on
staff if ever well we have started to
experience like experimenting with
bringing on some freelance help hustling
form of editors for the gaming channel
so I'm gonna assume this is like
full-time staff yeah employ yeah like
that's like a big step because bringing
on freelancers isn't super intimidating
it is a cost and it is it's a cost but
it's not a commitment yeah it's not a
commitment yeah yeah something like you
know someone relying on you to
continually produce enough income to pay
them that salary that's that's a lot of
pressure yeah I I don't know if I I
don't have a strong drive to yeah I
don't have a strong drive to now because
it does add a lot of pressure I mean
we're already you know we already put
enough pressure on our and I feel like
it would be a big stress even though it
would be a help as well I feel like it
would be a stress I would prefer to like
if we're gonna hire out help do it on a
consulting basis well I think another
lesson that we kind of learned from our
own journey you know making content and
making products and kind of going back
to our old business you know our old job
experience I think that what we've
crafted for ourselves was intentionally
a career path where we wouldn't need to
bring more people on where we could grow
as a company continue doing the same
thing but increase our revenue and like
per amount of our put in yeah you know
that was a very intentional decision on
our part I think another thing is like
you know we live in Texas it's super
cheap to live in Texas we only need to
make so much money to be craftable and
if we if we get to a point where our
options are okay we cut back on work a
little bit and make less money or we
hire someone so that we can continue to
make more money
we would probably just cut back on work
a little bit I think we would you know
we're at a point where we were
comfortable and we it wouldn't be a
stress what's interesting is we already
have you know with our buffer weeks
we've taken one buffer week and we have
more scheduled in the future which I'm
super excited about it's a huge stress
relief this yeah that's an example we
could have said like you know what we're
not able to get done what we want to do
every month so let's hire someone that
way we can do more stuff but instead we
said let's take a buffer week every now
and then so that we you know we won't be
making money that week but will be like
getting caught up on things and
relieving our stresses yeah and another
interesting thing is I mean I'm not
gonna mention any names or anything but
I've seen other companies bring on help
and I haven't seen like you know other
youtubers content creators similar to us
bring on help and I haven't seen or
heard of their hours reducing yeah it
seems like it doesn't really reduce your
hours it may be like can increase like
the quality of certain parts of your
output but maybe the amount of output
but I've never heard of it like oh I
have free time now yeah I've never heard
anyone who's brought people on say that
and I think like ultimately like if we
were gonna ask for anything like we
value free time over more money yes
which sounds funny because like we've no
free time right now but I think it's a
long-term goal yeah but I think like you
said bringing on someone doesn't
necessarily give you more free time so
we talked about some in episode 15 where
we talked about outsourcing and
diversifying and our week off in air
quotes but one of the lessons I've
learned over time I didn't really talk
about too much then but we've been doing
it for about two or three weeks now a
little bit of outsourcing and it takes a
decent amount of time not like if it
takes as much time as the other person
is saving you you're doing it wrong yeah
you might as well do it yourself but
it's not an inconsequential amount of
time managing yeah yeah you're going
instead of his doing the work you are
you know planning and scheduling and
reviewing and giving feedback and you
know shaping guidelines all that when
you when you're doing it via consultants
you can kind of like evaluate as you go
and adjust as needed but I think the
reason that I don't feel ready to bring
on someone full-time as cuz like you
won't you hire them you can't just like
evaluate and adjust on the fly like
someone is relying on you so yeah one
last point I think that also both of us
like to commit to a decision and if we
brought someone on we would want to like
really bring them on and I think that's
really intimidating to us to not only
because it's a commitment ongoing but
like with the freelance editors we hired
or like you know we paid for eight
people to edit eight different videos
and we've only used a few of them and we
ended up only continuing the
relationship with two and the idea of
going through that for like a full-time
employee and hopefully would get it
right the first time but that's a lot of
pressure yeah that's a lot of pressure
all right next question
okay we have a would you rather just
fitting cuz we just did what do you have
okay um so this is from Marcus um okay
would you rather a be blind and you have
the ability to make any object perfectly
without any tool so it doesn't include
the ability to restore or augment your
own vision or be you your deaf but you
have the ability to play any instrument
and any kind of music that's really
tough because I think that if I were
just choosing like which would you
rather lose your ability to see or your
ability to hear I think God I could both
stink but I think I'd choose to lose the
ability to hear I think I would too I
think that might have been one of our
would you rather but if I'm thinking
about what ability I would like to gain
I think it'd be cooler to have the
ability to make any object perfectly
yeah with any tool oh I think I said
without any tool before I don't with any
tool um I'd rather have that than the
ability to play any instrument because
we've always been both been more about
making things than like playing music
yeah so it's like neither pick the be
deaf okay I don't want to be blind yeah
i don't know i don't have you find it
yeah yeah and i guess the music is just
like a bonus the bonus yeah it's true
Kirsten asks what was your most
challenging project and why ah most
challenging project well and also um
what's been the most gratifying oh
there's a lot of questions okay we'll
start with what's your most challenging
project and why I think it's tough
because every time we start a new type
of thing that's usually the very like
it's a really tough moment to get
through you know like the very first
time we did like like the first big
shift that we did actually was when we
did 3d modeling and for the dust shoe
adapters and like we'd been doing like
tutorial project base videos we were
building something and all of a sudden
were doing 3d modeling and we were like
I forgot I don't know how to do this and
you know we well I think there's a
difference between what's the most
difficult project and what's the most
difficult video oh yes because when I
think of project I kind of think of it
in terms of the video because to me the
video is me project yeah but if we're
answering like just the project just the
project maybe a laundry room the laundry
room was pretty difficult yeah it was
just a little bit time-consuming there's
a lot of details to get right yeah the
Murphy bed wasn't another more difficult
one but it was like difficult because
different yeah actually like challenging
to get right I would say actually oh I
have an answer okay what's that
it helps though it would have been even
more difficult if we didn't have help
with it but the 3d printed knife
the one that we forged with Alec yeah
but like the 3d printing part of it
honestly was a huge part too like the
the whole project
so yeah the 3d printed Damascus knife I
forgot how many iterations we went
through and how frustrating it was to
like film like that that like
that a test again and again and again so
infuriating to film yeah because we had
to do so many variations so many minor
Rockies so many tiny adjustments and
then like doing the blade itself yeah we
had a lot of help
yeah I'm like the best person to help
Alex deal but even with help it was
still so much work with three of us like
taking turns working on yeah
yeah it was it was a lot of effort and
love put into that
yeah put into that knife and then a lot
of people asking for one and I'm like no
never again that's like a one-of-a-kind
thing forever and ever yeah no more ever
made yeah I would say that's probably
our most difficult project yeah that's a
good answer
I agree with that and there were
difficult videos to put all of that
together yeah concise way okay John from
MakerBot ass would love to hear about
the time in New Zealand that you Parrish
sighted out of an airplane I guess it
was right after getting lost on a hiking
trail where we almost died yeah okay so
if you haven't heard that New Zealand
hiking story we'll link to that story
we also jumped out of an airplane when
we were in New Zealand this was a few
years ago well we were like you know we
kind of had like a slight inclination
the sights like like curiosity like what
would parachuting be like and if we're
yes well if skydiving feel like if we're
ever gonna do it this is like the honor
% ideal place to do it it was beautiful
like lots of good reputable places to do
try that and stuff so yeah I don't know
what like to do it casual about it than
I was I was more casual about it until
we were up like 12,000 feet in the air
yeah did we do 1550 yeah something like
that is UK the highest you could so you
got like really as long as we're doing
it we might as well get the most time in
the air yeah makes sense logically yeah
it's like logically yeah if you're gonna
skydive at some point in your life and
you happen to be in New Zealand that's
probably when you should do it yeah and
if you're gonna do it you might as well
jump from the highest point you can jump
from and it was beautiful like it was
actually super awesome it was super
awesome okay so let's tell it an order
let's tell
when we got to the place that's when I
really started getting nervous I was
nervous the entire week leading up to it
man we like I think at some point we
pulled the trigger to like prepay for it
yeah that it would thinking that would
make me like not be nervous because then
I couldn't back out it was like decided
I think it did that for you yeah the
funny thing is I didn't really come
across really like until like we got
closer to it I didn't pick up on it like
earlier in the trip it was like once we
were in Queenstown yes I decided you
know crap weird something out of an
airplane soon and it I think like I'm
trying to think of the most
nerve-wracking part I think wins being I
think that when you're scooting towards
the door for me it was actually going up
in the airplane nerve-racking that was
like you know when like in horror movies
or scary movies how it like it starts
out like imagine that for like 15
minutes yeah just like you felt like the
tension does kept on building yeah cuz
like you know before before you actually
get in the plane they're kind of like
telling you things like they're teaching
you how to like okay when we jump you're
gonna like form a banana shape arms and
legs everywhere you did not banana but
they like give you all these tips and
you're getting geared up and you're like
okay and you're talking law and they're
taking pictures and you know what's
happening and then you get in the plane
and then it's just quiet
we were sitting next to each other and
we chatted a tiny amount a little bit
like nerve-racking you're in this tiny
plane and the plane is like it's like
flying in a tin can
it's like flying a long refrigerator a
sliding door yeah it's got a garage door
at the end of it it's really low there's
no seats you're just like piled in like
sardines literally like fit at all yeah
everyone's like sitting in each other's
laps
because you have every prison has
another person strapped to their back
and like you're just going up very
sharply in this tiny little plane and
you're like okay why didn't I just stay
down there funny a little break I'm a
large person and you know a parachute
can only take a certain amount of weight
and everything so they paired me with
like the smallest guy it's like the
smallest parachute shooter like trainer
if I hadn't stood up fully Hugh strapped
to my back yeah but like when we're
scooting towards the door hurt that's
what I was like oh crap what have I done
I think by the time we got to the point
where scooting because it was happening
really fast it wasn't like one person
with jump and then we'd all wait five to
ten minutes and then another person
would jump it'd be like one person would
jump thirty seconds would go by and the
next would jump see you're constantly
scooting down and it was like by that
point you're just in motion and we were
the last ones to jump first the first
one to be out might have been better
maybe we were the last ones we were in
the very back yeah so we were the last
two people to jump and like so we had to
watch everyone else yeah but by the time
it's you it literally happened so fast
it's like you have no control over yeah
there's no decision-making there's no
backing out it happened so fast you it's
kind of like you're walking along the
street and you slip out in airplanes and
just they just say like okay look up and
you look up and then you're outside of a
plan yeah what's really interesting is
the fall was wonderful awesome
fall like those I don't even know how
long two minutes three minutes one
minute yeah I don't know how long we
were actually falling I think was like a
minute and a half - yeah yeah but like
that fall was so fun it was so freeing
it was everything that I hoped for for
jumping out of a plane
yeah and it I had worried that you know
like when you you can't breathe no I
actually didn't worry about that I
worried about that
had heard from some people that it was
her breathe what I worried about was
like you know when you're on like one of
those rides that has a drop and you feel
it drop in your stomach yeah I was
worried it was gonna be that feeling for
like several minutes straight or orden
you're in an airplane and you you get
like get turbulence and stuff you know
it did I didn't feel like that I felt
like I was literally just like floating
they're very comfortable it's not like
you were floating with a really big fan
yeah yeah yeah just feel like you were
going down at all no no no it was very
comfortable and then they pulled the
parachutes and then that's when the
trouble started for both of us yeah
because I think that maybe cuz they
wanted to stay in a certain area or what
but they started circling for both of us
and neither of us can deal with circles
oh and I think that also we had such
adrenaline we we've had so much nerves
so much adrenaline so much nerves we are
already in like a fragile state and then
they start spinning us in circles and we
don't really we didn't really neither of
us have that like presence of mind in
that moment to say like can you go back
and forth in a line cuz circles are just
not doing it for me I did say I said
like I'm getting kind of dizzy yeah but
I didn't know what else to suggest is an
alternative yeah like when we both
landed both of us by that point it's
like we were like nervous nervous
nervous
whew fun oh I don't feel so good and
then by the time we landed both of us
were like seconds away from losing I was
first on my conscious second second so I
think like I don't know I think I landed
first I think I think you landed first
that means I was lost another plane yeah
because I remember like I landed and
they wanted to get a picture of us
together and as soon as I landed I was
like I'm going to throw up now right now
but then there was a person with the
camera and so I had to like hold it
together long enough to take a picture
and I was like okay I think I might be
okay I probably right there I wonder how
many people have like throwing up as
soon as they landed
vanna what are like what if some people
throw up in the air and this rains down
little bit oh oh so bad that be so bad
it's like I thought that the parachuting
part would be super chill super relaxing
I'm looking forward to that part always
thinking that be like my most fun part -
yeah but I did not enjoy that yeah but I
would like jump out of a plane if I get
to skip the parachute part jump out of a
plane and gone straight
yeah and just gone straight they'll be
great that'd be great yeah out of love
that that's like hanging in the air like
gliding down cool here's a question
would you do it again I don't know
there's an experience I'll always
remember yeah generally fondly yeah and
I don't really have an inclination to do
it again same there's some crazy you
know slightly less crazy but still kind
of on the crazy sad stuff that I'd like
to do it again it did happen yeah a lot
of it at like like one of the things we
did in New Zealand is there's a sport or
outdoor activity called canyoning where
you like rappel and climb down cliffs
and you go down like rivers and streams
new rapid yeah good on rapids and
everything that was fun I never would
have guessed that I would have liked to
do but that was fun like exploring caves
and caverns and stuff that was really
fun but like jumping out of an airplane
I don't know maybe one and done yeah
yeah and I don't think bungee jumping
you there yeah what about you
I don't know part of me thinks like I
might try bungee jumping only because I
haven't fire me things like I know yeah
but then I'm like already skydive like
I've proven my chops is that it I make
that up I think that you're like mixing
two together you chop your proves you
have chops I think it's like you have
tops you've proven yet your valor proven
your mettle prove your mettle and you
burn your chops I've proven that I am
metal and I have shops now
when you see I don't need one or two
more quick questions yeah would be fun
to do like more just general story time
there's so many we all we should do more
story times if you guys wanna hear more
story times let us know yeah we're gonna
do more story times in the vacations
right yeah we're gonna run out all right
one more from Tom Kelly if you could
create anything without worrying about
timeline sponsors money space tools etc
what would it be and this has been
something that I have wanted my entire
life basically like the dream workshop
yeah for me it's a little expanded
because the dream workshop and the dream
house to go along with it yeah yeah that
too yeah but the dream workshop in the
dream house it would be so great to like
craft something from the ground up just
over a long period of time just get
everything right and like this is the
strangest thing but like one of the
things that really bothers me about this
house this is getting lost on the house
side of things but like like the ducting
is bad it's just laying on the Attic
like there's like wires drooping
everywhere not properly managed it's
just like I want like the house like out
like you know that the walls aren't
right there's so many little things
wrong about this house and it would be
great to be involved in like the
construction of the house from the
get-go have power outlets everywhere
have like like server room have Ethernet
everywhere equally be down to have a
fixer-upper but one that like ability
either has the right bones already or we
have the ability to go in and fix all
those things in the beginning yeah in
the beginning like if we like lived in
one house and we were fixing up a house
nearby or something you know that's the
only kind of main situation I could
think of but I think that yeah for
though for the workshop it'd be great if
we had enough space and we talked about
like our ideal workshop a little bit in
our episode with April which link link
below but you know having every tool
every material yeah every like
capability where we just like where the
setup isn't ever a thing there's no real
barrier between wanting to make content
or make a thing and the execution of
that
yeah if you wanna make something you
just go stirring it yeah and and like
everything set up for filming to stop
winning and filming like we have all the
cameras we have the backdrops we have
the lighting we have the sound we have
everything set up so that there's no
friction to pursue ideas yeah because
right now there's a decent yeah yeah
yeah and I think like I guess to me the
reason I bundle the house into that as
well as cause like a lot of ours yeah a
lot of our work is in the shop edible a
lot of our work is in the house to like
our yeah this recording studio right now
this is a guest bedroom um you know and
other things to like like I think about
you know I would really like to spend
more time outside yeah you know like if
we had a nice covered that could be
really cool
or like you know it'd be nice to have
like I don't know because we hit a lot
of this comes down to like we don't
leave the house alive movie room yeah
just have like a really awesome house
yeah cuz then we really don't
yeah okay one more one more question
last question there's a lot more so
we'll try to answer those in future QA
segments let's go a lot of good ones
from will Burke what events like maker
fairs etc do you think hold the most
value for makers and different stages of
their hobby slash careers I think that
you know we have been to a decent number
of these now and I think that when
you're when you're first starting out I
think that's the most valuable time to
go I think because you get you get
exposed to a lot of other you know types
of making a lot of other people you can
kind of like when you're when you're
first starting out like the first
discussions you have with your fellow
people in real life that's so exciting
that was such an exciting moment for us
right our people you understand us New
York 2017 was our first like one since
we started and I think that I think that
uh you know so the other types of places
and events that we go to are like we
have spring make coming up we have
workbench con and I think I kind of
group there
more industry specific type of event now
for us that industry specific event our
content creators making stuff yeah and
you know my defend it might be different
depending on whatever industry you're in
but there's like the more general and
then there's more industry specific I
think go to one of each I know that's
not the answer you're looking for but I
think that we can describe what they
each offer so that you can decide what's
best for you yes okay so um maker fairs
are and if you're gonna if you're gonna
go I would say go to Bay Area or New
York like go to one of the big wins I
strongly agree um that's it's not gonna
be I mean that little ones do have value
but if you want like the full experience
go to one of the big ones those are cool
for the spectacle of it it's almost like
going I mean it is like a fair kind of
you know so it's it's just a fun cool
experience there's a lot of people there
also they're just for the fun cool
experience you can probably do some
networking some meeting of companies but
it's it's not built for that like if
that happens that's awesome and it
probably will happen a little bit but
it's not built for it yeah and I think
the way to take advantage of it
especially like you know a trip like
that is before you go see who else in
the communities go and reach out like
you know do a post on Instagram or
wherever you're like we know a lot of
people that like all reached out and you
know found out they all wanted to go to
the same event rented houses together
you know they travel together I think
you get a lot more out of it yeah
forming a group yeah and then like your
group will meet up with other groups but
I think that gives you like a basis I
think the other events so like workbench
con and spring make those the ones that
everyone's saying they're a little bit
more specific I think there's the those
are built for facilitating things like
network are networking like learning
skills you need to do like making and
content creation they are smaller
they're more expensive
and they like because they're smaller
it's it's just that core group of people
who are also trying to do exactly what
you want to do so I was like Maker Faire
there's a lot of people just there for
the fun of it you know I actually want
to do it professionally and necessarily
yeah and at the like more professional
focused events you can really go up to
anyone and start talking to them about
the things that you have in common
because you're both drawn there for a
very specific reason and everyone there
is basically on the same page so it's
really easy to talk to anyone about
something whereas at Maker Faire
some people might be there for their
kids some people might be there for the
robot races some people might be there
for you know a plethora of reasons you
know yeah yeah so I would say like if
you if you want to go there for business
reasons I might suggest like the
workbench Khan Spring make type of
things for specifically for like
networking if you want to go more as
like a observer and explore yeah I just
want to like observe and absorb cool new
things and like see technologies I
haven't seen before and like maybe get
some cool ideas that I can bring into my
own like the stuff that I make and be
inspired that might be more Maker Faire
yeah yeah so that's more kind of like
artsy and fun and the other one's a
little bit more business but they're all
super fun I mean with all of them yeah
we're going to spring make in a couple
days comes out we will be home you know
all right so I think let's wrap things
up with the thing of the week noise for
that yet no do you want are we gonna do
add another new noise we can we fully
said let's do noise the thing of the
week
the noise was there it wasn't my voice
alright so um speaking of travel and
events and stuff my thing of the week is
the man good job
checkin the Manfrotto travel tripod like
the video tripod now there's a lot of
different Manfrotto tripods oh my gosh
it's crazy you can get lost in all the
variations this one is the Manfrotto be
free travel like with the fluid drag
system and there's like two we will link
to it but you want the one with like
three legs the lever locks the fluid pan
system there's like a lot of reasons why
this one in particular is our favorite
because like you can fit this in a
backpack you can fit this into carry-on
it's still tiny dirty it's really sir it
has the fluid building I mean for photos
it's fine you don't need it but if
you're doing video you need a fluid
panhead media the fluid panhead yeah so
it's it's really interesting and it can
flip all sorts of ways it's really
versatile and stuff it made
collaborations so much easier yeah
before we we couldn't we had to do a big
we couldn't fit it in a carry-on stuff
in and once like crooked and I had a
partially disassembled it yeah like like
ruined my bags great but but having like
a really good travel tripod is great and
it's so great that's our secondary
tripod we use it yeah we use it when
we're not traveling very frequently and
it's like not that much worse than our
main one yeah it's like still a really
good tripod stand stone as a vane tripod
if you're me so I highly recommend it I
really like the system my thing of the
week is IKEA fake play yeah
we went on a little shopping spree
didn't we he did what do you went to
like yeah yes and I feel like every time
we go to Ikea 90% of what we get is fake
plans but it's like I mean you guys
they're a really good deal there you
guys know I can't I can't keep stuff
alive like I have like an aloe plant and
one
succulent and that's it my other a low
died which you're supposed to not be
able to kill a love confession time you
know those really pretty like yellow and
green flower things we put in our in our
front door makeover yet they did well
it's like we never wanted them and they
were in the shade all day yeah they did
think that it's like we're like but you
know what I realized
we don't we don't we don't really but
what I realized is nothing alive can be
there yeah you're right cuz it doesn't
get any direct Sun ever it doesn't ever
get any direct Sun I mean I'm sure
there's something that works but it
probably isn't native to Houston if you
can't handle sunlight and I don't know
hey they're still alive yeah cuz they
get Sun and rain oh yeah true that's
true they're still alive the ones from
the UM the welded go-cart video that
we've got for the patio those those are
still alive but the ones are a friend or
they did so what I decided is like
instead of doing research and finding
something that could survive with no Sun
and no rain I'm just gonna put fake
plants outside like is that so weird is
that weird
I don't know I think that it might look
make them look more real over time yeah
dirty don't get dirty though bother
they weren't that much more expensive
than buying a real plant like if I
bought two more real plants I probably
would have spent about the same amount I
spent on the fake plants yeah you know
what I mean like they're they're they're
not that expensive and if they're gonna
outlast the the real ones then there you
go
and this is a little bit like lesson on
our plates you know we just we just
can't deal with anything else meeting
our time yeah I feel weird cuz I don't
think other people put fake plants
outside like it seems very
counterintuitive I'm gonna do it huh
well you know maybe they'll be an update
in the future on how this is holding off
downside as fake plants can melt the
other day we oh yeah we had we had
family over when my mom was in town and
I was like I'm gonna light the candles
on our dining table but I also had fake
IKEA plants on our dining table and one
of the candles even though it was like a
full six to eight inches below the frond
of my fake fern melted the fake fern I
love the table you have the table
so I guess there's that is it down I
mean like you know real plant would have
died or caught on fire it would have
been worse it saved me and a real fan
would have grown back maybe yeah well
I'm I'm okay with the outcome outcome
yeah because IKEA fake plants are
awesome and like I would fill the entire
house of it I bet I actually mind we're
on our way to filling the entire house
with a key a fake plant almost every
rumor has one now yeah it's a little
family
yeah well fake plant family all right
well thank you for being part of our
podcast family today everyone thanks for
joining us thanks for all of the reviews
we really do appreciate that it really
helps us stand out on the charts and
everything and look for the charlie
message
[Music]